welcome everybody to the h3 podcasts
live thank you to today's sponsors honey
quit trippin and of course subscribers
like you just a reminder that if you
have Amazon Prime you can attach it to
twitch and subscribe for free
yes that's free2go com / I don't know
but you can subscribe for free it's free
money our first live show tickets went
on sale last week 14th
it's sold out in about 15 minutes and I
will say that's really cool and exciting
but there wasn't that many tickets it's
not like we sold out the Rose Bowl or
something but it was pretty exciting so
anyone who got tickets thank you for
that I think it's gonna be I'm super
pumped we may have a special guest that
will blow your mind
we may not though so don't know it's not
a promise but you're ready Mountain
ticket so you're going to get more than
you bargained for joined today by my
good friend and sweetheart who came
donned in garbs his garb derogatory or
is that I mean just means clothing right
as far as I know yeah but I mean at this
point you could pretty much link
anything to some sort of derogatory yeah
yeah garb is racist somehow guys
somebody heard about the marijuana thing
yeah that's a no-go now
he Cox from Smosh is here to co-host
with us today as we journey through
giggles laughs romps and writes through
this top of them I don't know why this
is a new thing I'm doing is pointing at
the camera like that we're touching tips
yeah I'm loving it it's powerful yes you
and ELA before we begin let me first
congratulate you on your new black book
err yes whack book errr the air it's the
pro the wack book bro but thank you and
yeah there's a little bit
a fight happening in our family right
now because Ethan is like anti a Mac
yeah I don't like mackerel product I
don't like the company I don't like the
product I don't like anything about them
and Gila knows that I feel this strongly
buts about it and so she's still going
behind my back this is like a cheating
hmm then I tried to tell him Ethan
please don't kill my vibe it's it's
never a good idea loyalty over
electronics because there's always gonna
be something that surpasses it a year
later like I used to I used to be a big
hater of denim jeans none of that's
electron now how can you hate denim I
don't know like I I didn't wear jeans
for like five years and I don't know why
would you wear corduroy I think I just
was trying to feel special about
something what do you just straight
chords you know yeah card just junior
agro cargo shorts this is right this is
early two-thousands okay it was
acceptable to wear cargo shorts khakis
are good a little it wasn't a good time
for fashion in general yeah the early
2000s you go back there yeah you know
you got you got Britney Spears in and JT
showing up in all denim right you it was
it was a push back on on what you saw it
was my revolt yeah I used to not wear
down and and actually I was funny I made
funny you said well would you wear
corduroy I said that because that's what
I used to wear yeah middle school I
would only wear corduroy pants and now
when I think but I'm not against denim
yeah I don't I'm not put us I've not put
like a stake in the ground sure like I
have with Mac Mac it's overpriced
the company I don't like the way they
run the company ELA gets in today the
first thing she's like oh my god I
forgot my dongle oh I need to sign it to
Apple ID future the future is the future
guess what guys we've got a really
exciting new invention where you have to
care
around the second piece if we want to
use headphones nicer now but now but now
it won't like if you accidentally yank
your cord it'll take your laptop off
with it right because I have an older
back book that has like the magnetic
thing right those I think kind of made
sense yeah it was like the so like the
old Xbox controllers how they had like
the cord the ripper yeah I had like we
would like rip away that's just gonna
take your laptop with it
of course I think that's actually what
Apple wants though especially after they
now that now that they made the iPhones
water-resistant I feel like they
resisted resisted they resisted for a
long time making their phones
water-resistant because they made they
want so much money because of people
dropping their phones and toilets we
could have done this decades ago oh yeah
they're missing out on a lot of money
now that of course now they make their
phones break easier right because now
they're all glass and everything yeah
you breathe on it wrong and they fixed
way so how much did that laptop cost you
EULA I cost me $3,400 damn and hurt yeah
yeah it's my money too by the way
but I so far I only had like this stupid
gaming laptops are pretty I'm not a
gamer but it's like who's really good
for anything you know I was like a razor
not a name-brand
yeah right we but it's like so bulky
it's here right yeah like whenever we
travel like I have back pain afterwards
oh it's awful she said I need a I need a
laptop that feels like air what I'm
carrying it around and apples like got
you fam whack book Eric was born this is
huge because we've always you know it's
passionate so mm-hmm
I let it go well here's what's happening
the stage is set for a tech off h3h3
tech reviews I'm shopping around to find
a PC or Windows machine that closest
resembles the wack book and so I am
looking at one and I'm doing it
specifically by weight right
they had slick it's it's so light right
this thing weighs about four point three
pounds likes water yeah my shredder
that's what a cutie pie that should
always be your metric like how many
shredders and weights yeah so I'm
looking for one shredder wait I want
basically the same way I think I'm gonna
be able to get a larger hard drive more
RAM a faster processor a better video
card for less but the question is you
will see the question is and it's not
even the matter of like processing speed
its usability its they got it I'll say
they've very sleek they're you've got a
slight thing going on this is not an ad
for any company which is coming with a
fart noise Dan seriously good idea
that's what I'm he's like do we have any
[ __ ] [ __ ] sounds I can blast and just
go good morning
AM radio I mean every once in a while
the the fart noise comes in handy yeah
it's not saying you overuse it but when
you can't discount a good fart yeah
anyway so the stage is set I think this
weekend I'm gonna get my own golden boy
PC stands for probably cooler this stage
is set for an epic tech battle until
then let's get enough about max let's
get on with it let's get on to I was
really important headline first story of
the day I think everybody's gonna be
wowed by if you catch my drift let me
open this in Australia they probably the
goofiest country in on the planet Earth
hmm hundreds of people gathered to say
wow like Owen Wilson let that sink in my
friends goofiest country on earth and I
mean that in a great way they're playful
they're fun I love mm-hmm
yep Owen Wilson is a very popular on the
internet for the way pronounces the word
Wow and now he's driving longing for her
that ever really know he has a thing
like in his movie
he always plays the same character and
he goes wow that's not the only word
that he says though he also has other
phrases that he's brought into other
things so he's like that's crazier than
a road lizard right he's literally said
that phrase and it was that's crazier
than a road lizard I don't think that
analogy is very compelling well he's
he's putting in a lot of his movies and
I don't know he does apparently a
disagree with me Owen Wilson saying Wow
so let's just see if this is actually a
meme before we get it definitely is so
here do you think the Wow is ever
actually in the script or that's just
always a tub of talent that's they
assume that when they get when they book
him it comes with a certain amount Wow
yeah yeah when the writing Family Guy
they're like we need you know twenty
jokes per minute mm-hmm so in Ellen's
case they're like we're gonna need ten
miles per scene it's fair that's fair
yeah so anyway let's get let's get back
to it
yada yada yada and these times I think
something as silly is getting together
and saying WOW can have a positive
effect and I'd like to see everyone come
together it could remind people that
this world we are lucky to inhabit is
beautiful and to embrace that like Owen
Wilson does in his movies by saying wow
wait did I read okay let's just watch
the ideal Wow
I like that guys focus on on his
campaign it just goes straight to the
chest and just hangs there
[Applause]
I'm kind of I'm kind of underwhelmed I
thought they were gonna give like a
countdown like three two one Wow but it
was just actually agree I was expecting
I wasn't it's a free for I wasn't
expecting a free for all
yeah y'all kept brought the time to come
together let's at least do it all come
on Australians the other I bet we can
put this together we wanted to we got to
do a different different phrase though
like they did the Wow we got to do
desserts in the robe or whatever
everyone knows home well yeah yeah I've
seen in Shanghai noon here's another
angle in case anybody was need to see
this do you think it's quite an hour
consulted Bibles
he's wild
all right well yeah I mean you know what
we're pretty great it's fun it's silly
it's fun it's playful
it's wow although it doesn't top my
favorite well which will of course
forever be mmm this class I don't have
ever heard the sound I've always just
seen it Wow yeah that's the best Wow
this guy man well Wow yeah I've never
actually heard the voice but it actually
it fit yeah he's great yeah that's a
closet
alright well I thought that was a lot of
fun let's get started waitis you know
open it up see what's out there some
good things you know so this next one
this stuff triggers me a little bit okay
so you guys may have heard of the story
of this hot teacher that [ __ ] her 14
year old student have you seen this
which one yeah it happens a lot I mean
it does seem to happen a lot it happens
from time to time let me roll this
report well let's start here 26 year old
science teachers Stephanie Peterson
walked into her first appearance at the
Volusia County Jail this afternoon
hoping to be released with just a
promise that she would be back to court
Volusia County sheriff's deputies say
Peterson engaged in a sexual
relationship with a 14 year old former
student of hers the teen told deputies
it began last November he said Peterson
would send him nude pictures of herself
she would also pick him up from his
house late at night so that they live
together investigators say the boy's
parents called law enforcement in
January and deputies arrested Peterson
on Wednesday
Peterson was charged with two counts of
lewd and lascivious battery and one
count of sending harmful material to a
minor her bond set at $25,000 and that's
why she wanted to be released on her own
recognizance today but the judge met her
halfway reducing her bond to $12,500 an
amount she posted almost immediately
dangerous winter storms are threatening
so well that's that's that's just
right so she hasn't been charged yet
that's true that's her bail but the
charges were just like lewd conduct or
something not like statutory rape which
is what you would expect to see if the
positions were switched that guy would
be like underground but the part the
thing that really the the reaction to a
story like this is very typical and this
is this the picture that everyone's
sharing here let me show you this is the
one that I see on Facebook and read it
where everyone's like oh man we're with
my teacher like that where's my fight so
she just sent the photos like she didn't
actually and everyone's like oh man
where was that where's that teaching
around the kid right my my counter to
that is is that this kid like people
think like when when when a young girl
has sex with an older guy how damaging
that must be right huh I think that it's
equally damaging for a man except they
just don't know it because society like
here's the comments on reddit everyone's
like that was awesome yeah of course
yeah you know what here's here's real
comments and where the [ __ ] were these
dream makers when I was a kid how damn I
wish I was that guy am I supposed to
pretend that if that woman [ __ ] when I
was 14 I would have been in a goddamn
paradise so as you said HeLa yet a horny
13 year old guy would would put his dick
in anything that moved right because we
talked about it earlier and I'm like
it's her responsibility not to do that
because it's so [ __ ] up when you're
like when I look back at myself at that
age oh my god I probably thought I'm
like an adult man you know yeah and by
now looking back it's like embarrassing
yes how you're not and just I don't know
it's him so he's 14 14 is kind of insane
my niece is 40 yeah but in that
perspective in my head
but the thing is like I think I barely
danced with a girl when I was 14
yeah I think I I almost kissed a girl
and ran away yeah
yeah that's that's I mean it's sketchy
it's sketchy it's it's just gross either
way so the thing is that like I think it
would damage somebody in ways they
wouldn't right like that's how you grow
up as a dude who tattoos on his arm like
big [ __ ]
like that's how you end up like someone
you know a couple of those people but
I'm saying like you will turn into a per
oh I think a worse person if this
happened you
it would [ __ ] with it would hardwire
your brain in a [ __ ] up way that you
it would do something yeah it's not good
it's not good
there was a reason it's not allowed you
know some of these comments this makes
me this makes me absolutely sick lucky
little [ __ ] I know it's a double
standard but when I was 14 and banging
my hottest [ __ ] teacher I'd be stuck I
seriously doubt this kid was damaged in
any way irresponsible and stupid on her
part yes it's not like she held him down
and forced herself on him we don't have
that I don't think that is well well it
doesn't matter I guarantee this kid was
all about it this would be what I
considered a victimless crime buying him
marijuana was she also bought a
marijuana by the way cool yeah so this
is a victimless crime but it's like
would you say the same thing of a 14
year old girl [ __ ] a 30 year old guy
and it's like oh she wanted it there
would be pitchforks yeah there would be
burning there would be burning of the
monster Frankenstein
anyway III always found this double
standard to be quite ludicrous yeah it's
definitely nothing new every time one of
those stories comes out people are like
oh yeah it's like good no it's still a
it's still a 20 was 26
yes 26 year old also in the relationship
of somebody in authority having a sex
with somebody they're supposed to be
taken care of yes is is twisted it's an
abuse of power yeah it's a little scary
yeah I don't know what was going through
either of their minds the kid he can't
he's blameless am i cause like yeah like
I said I put my dick and anything that
moved at that age literally that's
completely under adult
in that situation - in my opinion - all
right what do you think about it dad one
more thing for teachers to worry about
you can't even I can't [ __ ] my teenage
students anymore yeah that's true and I
got a carry gun wait you're telling me
I'm not getting a racist here and I
can't affect my 13 year old students
darn well at least I'll have a gun you
know what I love about this argument
about arming teachers hmm just like two
days ago there was a story of a teacher
barricading themselves and shooting up a
classroom yeah let's give them more guns
the least stressful job in the world
they'll be fine [ __ ] insane it's
gotta be one of the most insane thing
I've heard arming teachers yeah we
talked about it last episode but it's it
really I'm sure the comments love that
discussion I'm sure everyone is really
civil and kind in the comic you know
what I would love to hear if there's
anybody out there who genuinely believes
that we should arm teachers you want to
have a conversation about it Colin are
we ready for Colin Stan we weren't we
are not during the break so if you're
out there and you think oh let's give
teachers guns elementary school teachers
guns Colin let's talk about it I'm all
for arming teachers as long as we get
those smart bullets that avoids the good
guys and just only hits the bad guys
because apparently Apple is working on
that really help you need the log in
mid-air here I phone account so anyway
that's Story number two Wow can we get
that on the sound board please Dan yeah
definitely with a fart directly after it
just this this show is developed in Big
Time - welcome Cheers up next Papa John
severs ties with the N
F Wow and and even worse than that is
that they've been replaced by pizza
mm-hmm do you think Papa John's mention
is that risk Papa John's Pizza mansion
yeah um no I sold enough pies by now man
I I hope I was doing okay better than
the delivery guy I'm sure yeah as long
as he doesn't turn out like the kid that
played Anakin oh yeah oh yeah he was not
happy about being Anakin he got trashed
on him and he was going to school and he
I feel bad got all messed up
he got messed up and then like the kid
who played young Darth Vader and the
original prequels really everybody
trashed on the support kid cuz he was an
awful actor and he was an awful actor
but it's not his fault he's eight year
old right and so when he grew up and
went to school you know you can imagine
the torment that this poor kid went
through that's not the kid was an awful
actor yeah it wasn't it wasn't ruined
ruined Star Wars for me if you look at
the prequels is it really the actors
faults well old Anakin kind of there are
good kid actors and when you're making a
Star Wars prequel with the budget of
like 50 billion you there's a good
there's a good connector out there can
imagine it's also hard to write for
children because most of people that are
writing these are like I don't know 30
40 50 years old right and now they're
trying to write in the mindset of a
child right yeah that is a talent though
that writers do have right there are
writers maybe yeah
I'm just saying they have the resources
there like here's 50 billion dollars we
can find someone who can write the
dialogue of a child and we should be
able to find a child they could do
though you're saying people should blame
the writers not the kids your blame
George Lucas I'd say yeah I'd say blame
the writers more than more than the
actors you can like a good actor can
only act so good yeah with the script
that they're given I think writers don't
give it interesting enough pressingly
we've started at Papa John's Papa John's
who I will say we approached for a
sponsorship deal they said no Shh I'm
like I sell more pies than Peyton
Manning and all those guys on the field
I sell more Papa John's Pizza than Papa
himself you're saying no to me well I've
got a word I got something to tell you
Papa if you don't get smart and make a
deal with me now I'll be your new NHL
I'm gonna be switching to Pizza Hut
so Pizza Hut took their place yeah
the announcement came a day after Papa
John said with ended sponsorship with
the war it is a pizza it's a legitimate
pizza war it's a hot war unlike a cold
war no Papa John's is less well if it
was Papa Murphy's it could be a cold war
because that's like the takin bake Papa
Murphy's Oh old war I don't know we need
another so well Papa Murphy could have a
cold war with digital uh yeah yeah sure
[Laughter]
like I said this is big Papa John which
last week blamed the NFL's response to
players protesting for slumps and sales
will focus his partnership on individual
teams what an idiot by the way like even
if you disagree with all these NFL
players protesting don't be like yo our
pizza sales are dropping so you all need
to stop whatever you're doing this is
the NFL is exist to sell pies people the
pizza went into his head
he's gone pizza that's gone to his head
you're right
man that guy's face looks like he's been
a little bit too much time near a pizza
oven you know what I mean yeah I'll
pitch Sean Shatner let's pull up a
picture him and by the way I yeah he's
definitely got a sponsor he was a
cautious Papa John what stuff what do
you think Papa John watches for
entertainment news fox news probably Fox
and Friends all day just like torture
videos maybe slaughterhouse yeah hey put
on uh oh look at that that's a face
that's been around a pizza oven I feel
like this guy just watches a lot of
Baywatch oh and dad yeah I can totally
see this Baywatch all day yeah why'd
they blur the
like the sad music I don't know where I
am but I'm into poor papa
everybody can if you have any lighters
please get them out now
poor went out for the Papa put a slice
on the ground for Bubble Boy yes oh I
want that jacket though that I swag papa
the league's deal with pizza is for four
years and is worth more than Papa John's
deal uh-oh the agreement gives pizza
which is owned by Yum Brands an
exclusion brand that's fake pop fake
name yum-yum I feel like that's like
Japanese like a Chinese company they own
secretly owns every that's like somebody
that's like we need to make a company
that's like a food company what we call
it um well that's why I think it's
Chinese because they always do that
they're just like we need a we need to
we make we sell meat let's call it wolf
or something it's the Chinese [ __ ] man
Papa John said Tuesday the company
reported that its sales were down four
percent from the year before wait for
four percent that a lot I think in the
pizza world probably
well I remember he threw up a stink when
health insurance rolled around Obamacare
that giving his employees health
insurance was gonna cost him like three
cents more per pie and he thought that
that was remarkable enough that him
saying that publicly would be convincing
even though everyone ripped him for it
cuz like everyone's gonna get that was
gonna sympathize yeah everybody's fine
with my employees you know being broke
you say cancer whatever just but people
like ya three cents I don't even I who
even carries pennies I literally throw
pennies on the floor it's it's it's a
health hazard
I feel like pennies are a health hazard
right when you get enough pennies I mean
you can't I mean that could buy a whole
new papa mansion though he's got to
worry about that that'll be a good video
you should watch it you've seen that
trend on YouTube buying stuff with
pennies buying Gucci clothes with
pennies you know funnily enough it
connects back to us cuz it was the
Bradbury's little brother who had
that viral hit did they started I think
they may have had they I no offense to
them but I don't think there would ever
be have any original thought of the show
they got something going on there what
are you talking about I've heard about
like somebody went like the DMV they had
some sort of ticket they had to pay off
and they they paid it off in pennies I
was talking about that with my friend
and and and he was like that's that just
mean that the office worker didn't give
you that ticket and now you've just
burdened this person with a hundred
thousand just a revenge thing yeah so in
the case interestingly in the case of
you're paying bills for a
government-issued bill they have to
accept any currency by law that make
sense but in the case of Gucci they're
like get out you [ __ ] hooligans I
actually want to see if they invented
this let's see sort by aren't you
curious if they invented it or not we
can figure this out you can't it would
also help if you spelled penny correctly
any well it's pennies used they always
say penny ah I do need the F to complete
the thought so here there's this one
month ago Wolfie I actually think Wolfie
may have met today he seems more
creative by being Frank they're all from
one month ago though oh here you go
fine oh you know what let's just get
into let's just get right into it
so the Bradbury's have been insane
[ __ ] little brother
this kid scarcely there's another one
Omar bro how many Bradbury's are there
three that I real we know but you know
in the wintertime the berry it's berry
season yeah and those berries flourish
oh man weather like this
[Music]
amazing - covered couch they change all
the way back first video about them I
have to presume so but they're killing
it with all these penny videos why don't
they go get up [ __ ] well he's young
he probably that's probably their
parents house hmm they have to know that
doing shooting a video on a
plastic-covered couch is not a good look
I think that should be self a parent
does the camera ever like stop there's
always something happening on the screen
it's kind of an interest overload it's
doing that they had the presence of mind
to just keyframe in and out non-stop cuz
it I mean it take not a lot of effort
work this is finally new for me and we
can just go through the Gucci store and
buy something from Gucci hopefully they
do accept that because nothing was taken
[Music]
I'm surprised have to give him credit
for all the editing two suitcases three
suitcases four suitcases five suitcases
filled what ten uh yeah guys one more
shoe cake never seen this in your light
race right here they come this is kind
of a couple young guys walking through
the mall with a bunch of suitcases right
I'm hoping that they're just panties in
there oh man how are we gonna make our
video then so they just go there they
got kicked out and that was an 18 minute
long video I've no idea than that my
dude have you lost time you've had a
five million video Wow I'd have to look
usually it's all it's always just kind
of like a consistent like I don't know
because we I mean I guess clearly we
need to start making video that's what
I'm driving at is that Wow how old is it
like super young Omar he's about 30 he's
about 14 just right the the right age to
have a high school teacher but do you
think he's doing all the editing nah nah
I think they have like I honestly think
that um Tennessee does the editing mmm
Tennessee TV remember that guy mm-hmm
down the mean pole we go I don't know
it's a theory well anyway my point is I
haven't got five million views in a long
time
we need to team up Rango
she panty shopping yeah what if the
whole video was just cake we got to do
it bigger than that though we got to go
down to Mexico with pesos and hit up the
Gucci store there oh yeah it doesn't
feel although yeah that would go buying
a car buying a yacht with pennies show
up with like another yeah anyway this is
this this is going on too long this
penny mean Papa John got fired and I'm
still here where are you well now he's
got money to spend some pennies for days
papa
hit him up Papa yeah that's my point so
anyway guys we are gonna go to a quick
break stay tuned so much more laughs and
gaffs left don't go away
thank you to honey for sponsoring this
episode of the h3 podcast
would you ever turn down free money no
no who would do that well if you shop
online without the best coupon you're
already paying too much how many stores
online alike oh this item is usually
$1,000 except with this coupon that
we've only told some people about it's
actually two hundred and fifty it's
actually five dollars that doesn't
happen anymore
with honey which is a free browser
extension that finds the best coupons on
the web so you know you're always
getting the best price this app is a
revolution in two clicks add honey to
any browser for free and then just go
ahead and shop like you normally would
honey scans and tests millions of
coupons in the background like an old
Jewish father clipping coupons silently
in the darkness like my dad used to clip
coupons not you that was like he work
all day and he'd come back and clip
coupons that's what it's doing for you
all the time wait like me I don't have
coupons I use honey effort I check out
honey will automatically apply the best
coupon to get you the biggest discount
over 7 million people use honey every
day and together saved millions of
dollars when honey's got your back
you'll never overpay again just the
other day
we were ordering parts on Amazon true
story before based on true story this is
not this this sometimes movies be like
based on true events this is true events
movies be like crying laughing emoji we
were ordering parts for a new computer
on Amazon dance putting it together and
he's like hunting just saved me ten
bucks on Amazon hold $10 what wasn't ten
how much was it exactly I wrote it down
because I was so impressed it was nine
dollars and 41 cents that's ten dollars
pretty much yeah I just want to be
authentic as possible because we've
emphasized how real the story 941 and
what it did is like oh this processor is
available from another seller still
Amazon Prime by the way Hamazon prime
shout out to you twitch prime I was like
a ghostbusters cross this James thing
and so what they do because Amazon's got
all these different cells they
automatically pick one that's cheaper
and still prime its equal in all the
ways just $10 less 941 it was incredible
there's no reason not to add honey to
your browser it's free takes just
seconds to install and will save you
tons of money add honey to your browser
for free right now at join honey calm
slash h3 that's join honey calm slash h3
you're gonna be taking a dive into your
Uncle Scrooge coin pool before the end
of this copy read so like we need a
close-up camera on there touch finger
cam did that image make sense the what
do you call it the Scrooge McDuck
Scrooge McDuck yeah there you go you're
gonna be Scrooge McDuck in your way to
prosperity with honey join honey calm
selected I read that right that's the
link rasher did yep next up thank you to
quip oh man I just got my new quip I got
my new head this morning I attached it
we got it in blue this time I was like
actually I wish we brought it it's a
really beautiful color matches my
kind of let me tell you about quit for
those who are not yet been initiated
into the quip army quit is one of the
best inventions of the past 100 years
right behind I would say the internet
internet air travel quit quit is an
electric toothbrush that's so silly k--
and so hot and so easy to use it
vibrates first of all talk to any
dentist and they'll tell you vibrating
toothbrush cleans your teeth better
next up Thank You EULA for the vibrating
yeah thank you for the how do you call
that the folly I don't know it's not
really it's not really fully if it's
actually coming from the toothbrush
though is it three effects at times your
brush so you know you're getting the
best possible clean it vibrates every
thirty seconds just to say keep going
man you're doing great your breath
stinks and you need all the help you can
get and then all of a sudden three
minutes past it goes weren't wearing
worm and it turns off and you're like
I'm ready I'm set I got the best brush
my breath doesn't stink I'm not gonna
get gingivitis I'm ready and besides
that it's got the softest greatest
bristles I'm a toothbrush fanatic
I love quip it's my favorite toothbrush
I cannot recommend it enough just try it
it starts at just $25 you've got nothing
to lose
it's so important we brush our teeth
every day or you if you're not I mean
there's people I swear to god they're
like oh I just I brush three times a
week I'm like do you any taught and you
talk to be like this I feel like if you
don't brush regularly and you all can
feel it from here almost one of those
guys and don't be one of those guys
where you can see like [ __ ] caked onto
your teeth you gotta brush twice a day
to like not not even you're talking
about every day I mean dentists
recommend three times after every meal I
gotta admit I don't do three sometimes I
do three but to to is gonna you're gonna
need to you're gonna need to at least
let me as your dentist advise you on
that try this toothbrush it's gonna
change your life it's gonna make you
wanna brush because it's so fun quips
starts at just $25 go to get quick calm
/ h3 right now you'll get your first I
don't know why I'm pointing all this I
know it's fun though hey you I had to
join get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush that's
your first refill pack Ferrari at get
quipped cough / h3 that's spelled GE TQ
u IP comm / h3 give it a shot
help support the show support our
sponsors you're gonna love this
toothbrush I guarantee it if you don't
love this toothbrush - come find me and
tell me about it
that's don't if you see me on the street
talk to me about clip thank you finally
- trippin comm ever plan a vacation
finding a place to stay
that'll make everyone happy for the
right price where you all want to visit
well it can feel like a full-time job
that's true
finding a hotel it makes me sometimes
want to just cancel the whole dress
spend less time planning your next trip
with trippin dot-com don't visit a ton
of sites on trippin calm once search
lets you compare every home from the
world's top vacation rental sites in one
place to find the best deal on your
perfect vacation rental vacation rentals
offer more more privacy more space for
everyone under one roof and more choices
with fully stocked kitchens oh man I'd
be like oh [ __ ]
they'll regret giving me that option
there'll be like three grains of rice
uncooked rice left in the pantry when I
done tearing that up and extra bedrooms
and even hot tubs Wow well Wow all the
comforts of home and then some
best of all tripping calm you can join
the millions of travelers who find more
savings with rates up to 80% less than
traditional hotels that means you can go
anywhere you want and get a wonderful
accommodations for a fraction of the
price alright so if you're planning
Spring Break on the beach of Florida
trippin comm let's say you're dreaming
of sitting on the deck of a smoky
mountain cabin tripping calm
maybe you want to go to Mars tripping
car that's right this year's save time
and money when you book your vacation
home of your dreams with tripping Cobb
slash h3 that's tr IPP ing Cobb slash
age three so the next time you're
looking to plan your perfect vacation
home don't trip don't trippin
yeah that was the one that we coined
last time right don't trip balls just go
to trippin comm / H Street but seriously
please support our sponsors if you want
to support the show if you are in the
market for a toothbrush you're going on
a trip or what was the first or in the
market for generating free revenue and
this isn't a big connects community
whatsoever in the copy reads at the very
bottom tree ban what's up what's up
what's up honey nation it's not a scam
back to the show everything's legit
please for our sponsors let's get back
into the show
[Laughter]
welcome back everybody to the a street
podcast live with ela kleiner for life
and on my great wonderful friend and he
[ __ ] head [ __ ] are he come he got it
right the first time he [ __ ] yeah hard
on the e yeah
always go hard on the E no I thought
what that sounds wrong that's bad go
hard on the Gerard before the [ __ ] boom
I don't know we were talking last about
Papa John and then this other little
ditty came up related to the Pizza Hut
NFL story that I thought was really
interesting Pizza Hut replaces Papa John
as NFL sponsor but guess what they're
also developing a self-driving pizza
delivery service check this weird [ __ ]
out Pizza Hut is teamed up with Toyota
dis G large herbs test out self-driving
and delivery vehicles that will steal
your jobs now what you see here is
they're gonna scan your face put it into
the government database basically you're
selling all of your human liberties
right share we do pizza you are selling
your future kid it's out of fare jobs
every college student now is out of work
and the price of pizza has dropped the
tenth in a world where drones are flying
is all coming from the need to deliver a
pizza exactly it's the most important
issue of our time here ok bro people
can't melt a piece of bread with cheese
in their house
why what's going on exactly here this
juror this high-tech drone is delivering
to like the president of New Zealand
yeah get a slice I am kidding this is
actually really cool but more I think we
need to get real about tech stealing not
but John when will Papa John's join the
competition holder calling him out in a
car Oh with this old dear friend Peyton
Manning ah not anymore
Peyton doesn't answer Papa's calls
anymore pain we used to be pals so this
video is by Pizza Hut
let's CNN tech I can definitely see the
the delivery working if if you had those
going to say like a ball like a ball
game like when it gets out you know
everybody's drunk they're leaving the
game and you got this giant Pizza Hut
Delivery drum that's just selling just
like a like a almost like a robotic food
truck yeah cuz I feel like that would
work that would kill large sort of
gathering places where there's where
there's you know not usually always
people there I don't think it makes any
such as a viable real world I don't see
why not that so that the the thought is
that they team up with Amazon and other
delivery services throw it all on this
car and everything yeah the pizzas like
well anyway my might the thing that I
thought was like let's get real guys
computers are taking our jobs and we
need to get smart people ok now if you
think that oh I'm I've got way more
skill than a pizza delivery boy I'm I
write I'm an engineer I'm gonna I do all
this really cool stuff and no one rather
place me think again watch this think
again all of our jobs are at risk during
a 2005 show songstress Fergie could not
ignore nature's call so there's all
these YouTube channels is he using like
deep learning or whatever they call that
why how deep it is it's just
is a super-deep I think actually all it
is is the okay so I this has to be
coming out of India I just have a
feeling these programmers set up
something to read an article steal a
picture from it Auto read it and then
they automatically post it on YouTube
so these channels with these really
goofy cringy voices and they upload like
200 videos a day yeah and the crazy
thing is they're probably making Bank
but as they should I mean this is
quality but anyway yeah so I mean if you
think that you're too high skilled to be
replaced by computer
journalists youtubers we're all at risk
the singers pants oh wow
someone's got to fix the road afterwards
no robots are gonna be fixed and robots
we're all scrub out see me fixing
themselves fixing each other it's gonna
be crazy that she had peed herself to
cover it up she quickly doused herself
with champagne good thinking Fergie
thank you for watching subscribe to my
channel no it's not even subscribed to
my channel subscribe my channel it's
vivid world my dude that's the name of
the yeah yeah how many videos they have
can you get yeah let's see how do I see
see but 32 thousands subscribers how can
I see how many videos they have I don't
know that I can do that but you hear you
can see just 11 hours ago they uploaded
oh wow yeah like 20 videos Wow yeah
thank you all which will include a visit
to Jordan will take place in the summer
is this how you like to get you know
wife Kate minutes better than Alexa but
so what that was leading into was this
wonderful video now we're gonna get into
the deep cringe the deep deep cringe my
dude
Fergie drunk at the award show have you
seen this I heard about it
I did not see it I guess I saved saved
myself for you it's honestly really
quite hard to watch this is like some
real deep cringe and I mean like in the
real sense people have lost an
appreciation for what that actually
means it's harder and harder to come by
now because I feel like a lot of
companies now are preparing for really
cringey moments knowing you can't have
this happen we can't have bowen you know
like a soup like the Janet Jackson super
bowl moment right well keep preparing
because here we go the intros super
wheels
[Applause]
so what happened just a little backstory
cuz he's like I don't know what I'm
supposed to do she was supposed to come
out present but the producers realized
she was so shit-faced that they're like
nah dude go out and do it and so this
poor guy is really in the middle of
something special
no hi Fergie I'm actually army hammer
thank you
I'm gonna win at the Academy Awards
thanks Brett he's even watching okay so
this is unexpected and in typical twos a
yes style I think you would love that if
he was here
[Applause]
really in her mind she's killed you know
what I mean
Tom for real her there's like a
five-second pause in between every word
she says
what is she using here on this bag he's
here on this amazing t-shirt mock style
long sleeve shirt and fabulous but he's
also here as a person and the thing is
all of the Tom Ford life which I thrive
to get and was really embarrassed that I
didn't have chumford makeup in my bag by
the way channeling it in their mind he
is a person with compassion he's a
director he loves to see people's
feelings and listen look at his face is
so good yeah he's just man young dog you
didn't bargain for this at all this is
not a shameless promotion
somebody help somebody do something I
can't move new song called a little work
family she peed herself to to the
previous project I have a version that
has alternate verses and so are you
shameless late no shame with shame I
promote the target he's trying to sneak
out shuffle to the side oh man
yikes I feel bad for her in a way
because she was nervous didn't work out
yeah I often have this feeling when I go
to a like a gathering and I get drunk
and I'm like man I'm I'm sure everyone
thought it was such an idiot
yeah in this case in this case I don't
worry about it as long as it's not
recorded right I'm sure I've said or
done some pretty dumb things but
definitely made sure I wasn't gonna
record it yeah Cheers now I just enjoy a
cold she doesn't call him same one else
drink like this there's me hmm nice
technique everyone
so anyway her rep was saying her PR guy
was saying it was just a gag aha well
it's like to bring it back to the to the
room tell me why so after it achieved
cult status then he was like oh yeah you
know this is a comedy that's a yeah yeah
it's totally comedy yeah totally
the same guy said that um the pee
herself thing was just wet or something
brutal sweat man she's clearly got a
fallen on hard times here oh yeah she
did
you know she got a lot of [ __ ] for the
anthem yeah did you see that no that's
what I thought you were gonna show me we
can watch that no no it's fine I'm sure
everyone else is already seeing it let's
watch that but my take on it was that it
wasn't nearly as bad as everybody was
making out see ya well is it Mariah
Carey New Year's Eve
no more like she tried something
different and it didn't really work
she tried you like a sexy sultry version
yeah but it's funny that yeah okay let
me see that's Fergie apologizes for it
may have been just it's wait I don't
know where are you gonna find that man I
feel bad for her dude
have you seen the Jimmy Kimmel New
Year's Eve compilation it's like 9
minutes long it's it's the most supreme
cringe video ever it's real bad another
example why you don't get drunk when
you're on camera
yeah Jimmy was cringing sorry not jimmy
kimmel Oh Jamie Kennedy sorry yeah did
like a New Year's Eve celebration thing
on Hollywood Boulevard and everyone was
clearly clearly trashed
can you put can you find that backs back
there guys I think we watch that on the
podcast one oh yeah
where it's like it's on it's like KTLA
and they their production is just
completely training at Kennedy yeah and
they're like cutting away mid-sentence
for people and yeah there's a good girl
in the background reading the
teleprompter of what the guy was saying
on camera so just a short excerpt from
this article the whole performance
lasted about two minutes which was more
than enough time for everyone watching
to roast Fergie on all social media
platforms even the comedian Roseanne
Barr took a shot at her I don't know why
they made a special note of Roseanne
Barr yes that Roseanne who once sang the
national anthem like this okay whatever
I'm out of this here's a good one oh I
got the video what what did I miss in
this one dead air yeah I mean it's a
long video but oh my god this is great I
feel well let's just go back to the
beginning cause I wanna say it's a big
deal they roll in live and they're on
there in front of the Chinese Theater
okay Hollywood Boulevard New Year's Eve
as a live-action somebody's teaching
something in the back let's check it
with stone there's so much to point out
it's like a Where's Waldo of cringe it's
so much to see David's life yeah let's
check in with Stu stone who was with
Shannon Elizabeth Wow in here with us
tell everybody what is gonna happen in
2014 with you I'm so excited 2013
this use the broadcast doesn't appear
they just accident yeah they gotta cut
around the and they're back now
same
producers just setting up are we back I
wonder if there was a year piece
malfunction because I've done a shoot
where my earpiece didn't work I think it
takes more than that look like it was
out of his ear earlier so maybe he's
getting static and had to pull it out or
something I love this it's resulted -
it's live and he's screaming
are we back this is wonderful oh man
this is my worst nightmare forever
forever doing anything like so good
we're gonna throw things over to Jamie
Jamie what's going on over there are you
jealous that I'm hanging out with a hot
playboy model and a really hot burger
[Music]
you'll see what I mean check this out
it's a black screen nothing who dropped
the ball here how is there so many
mistakes wait and then it's just like a
random clip from the laughs actor no way
they like rolled the wrong clip is that
real all right now watch the girl behind
him that's even greener than Jamie and
probably just could be so sick girl
right behind his limp is lip syncing the
dialogue because he's just reading a
teleprompter yeah
gentlemen please welcome Anna Rosales
hello Anna I got questions I know you've
got answers can you tell us first and
foremost how can we improve the energy
efficiency in our homes what's this some
poppin ears
material Oh God Macy Gray this is the
worst but I forgot about this there was
a recent Macy Gray cringe wasn't there
look into that and I think there's
something spicy that reason I find this
part just makes me feel
[Music]
the background is really hard on the ice
too isn't it it's like a really really
nice to look at too early so she's like
yes like compared to whatever else is on
TV on New Year's evening mm-hmm I feel
like this has got to be the most
entertaining program oh my god yes but
not for the right reasons yeah yeah no
but I mean at the same time what's your
resolution for 2013 you like same exact
resolution al out of the white people
[Music]
they're just open to the public at this
point you know they say once you go
black you should try white because it
will keep you for China very tight yeah
and then like as they're closing out and
the cameras like pulling out and they're
supposed to be celebrating there's like
a fight going on literally running out
out of there okay oh it's always fun to
relive that let's take some calls I have
a lot of other stuff lined up but I
let's see what they've got
okay we've got an ex-army vet believes
that there should be more security on
campus I mean I'm not gonna argue with
that necessarily we have Jake who's a
gun owner believes teachers should be
able to carry with proper training hmm
let's talk to that let's start with the
ex-army vet that sounds more like more
authority hello drew how you doing bud
thanks for calling in you there what's
going on there how you doing hey thanks
for calling in of course of course
self okay what so what is your position
on arming teachers ants in public
schools I mean I definitely think it
shouldn't be as hard to get into a
hospital or an airport as it should be
that the few
sure who I don't have any kids but the
future is the kids today so I know in my
city in Boston and the surrounding towns
I could just walk into a high school or
an elementary school because I have
little brothers and I go to pick them up
and it's too easy so I I don't know
about arming teachers and obviously we
skiing what happened when there is
security and I know where I'm from they
have littoral police there and they did
in Florida that are armed so something
needs to be done I don't know about
arming teachers especially but they're
just definitely needs to be more
security as to getting in and yeah I
don't know I don't know where I stand
the ball I won't disagree with you there
I definitely think that I mean there was
a guard there and he yeah that's that's
the argument is that there was there was
an armed guard there and and wasn't
stopped and you know schools are huge at
least with with my school that I went to
there was I think a couple thousand
students and yeah it's a large open
campus it's not a self-contained
building right and you know kids snuck
out and snuck in all the time is this a
feasible to like you know back to school
like you would have airplane yeah it's
like how much how much is you know I
guess I guess there's no there's no
saying that that a armed guard is gonna
stop them but it's a deterrent mm-hm and
I guess that's that's the most that we
can hope for mm-hmm
my thing is I don't think these could
these people who shoot up schools would
be deterred by anyone with a gun because
they're they're on a suicide mission
already they all die they know how it
ends right they all get killed by the
police or kill themselves a lot of times
so let's try one more Jake here okay
how's it going Jake thanks for calling
in so you are a gun owner that leaves
the teachers should carry weaponry
expand on that well I mean for me
personally coming from like a strong
firearms background and he helped me to
want to get before me but I was
I'm a Marine Corps vet oh so I mean just
given like proper training if like we
can send 18 year olds to go to
Afghanistan and die I don't see why
someone who's in their 20s and around
kids violation given the proper training
be allowed to carry and conceal a weapon
if they throw too well so you're you're
saying someone who's ex-military should
be a teacher we need to overlap those
two you said we can send people off at a
teenagers to trainings right okay so
like but like a highly trained
professional if there's a highly trained
highly trained professional at the
school then they should be allowed to
carry who's also a teacher yeah do you
think that it's putting too much
responsibility on the teacher in a way
to expect them to not only be like to be
educators and to go to college for that
and to have their mind be about
educating and taking care of kids but to
also have to undergo extreme training to
carry a firearm and be prepared to
confront an armed shooter in the case
that that would happen
doesn't it seem like it's asking a lot
oh no I I know a lot of people who do
that like in their free time like who
are very successful people in the
business world and in their free time
they go undergo that training by
themselves so I don't think that's too
much to ask it's not imagine like I
don't think it's not mandatory that
every teacher should carry I'm saying
have any choice even the toy right is
there do you think that there's any are
we talking kindergarten through high
school do you think that a kindergarten
teacher you should have a gun or does it
not matter to you what age I mean that
kindergarten teacher feels that those
kindergartners are a threat or they're
in danger I don't see why they shouldn't
have the option and do you think like so
in my mind having more guns in schools
creates more opportunities for something
to go wrong because as we were
mentioning earlier in the show
you have the situation of this teacher
that barricaded himself in the classroom
and shot up the school because we have
like a lot of people who are advocates
of gun control will say we have a mental
health problem so if that's the case and
we all agree that there's a mental
health problem and not enough people
being treated do you agree that putting
more guns in schools increases the
likelihood instead of decreasing that
more children will die I don't think
that that's so much the case I think
that like as part of the training they
would also go under the like a mental
health screening as well I guess right
do you think do you think it would be
fair like oh sorry I was think would be
fair if if there was a shooter on campus
say they had a an assault rifle and the
teacher had a handgun and the teacher
chose not to engage the shooter would it
then be on the teachers would it then be
the teachers fault for not engaging the
shooter well I think it comes down again
to my personal choice they feel like
they would be a asset to that situation
then they should have the right to
engage with that that's actually a great
point in because it's like a can of
worms in a way like you see how
everybody's railing on this guard who
didn't engage yeah and they're like
naming him and shaming him so when you
open the door for teachers to have guns
and say one does have a gun because now
all the sudden that's just acceptable
because for whatever reason now when
someone there is a shooting that teacher
if they choose not to engage for
whatever reason their life is gonna be
ruined I think almost certainly by
everyone who's shaming them for not
engaging it's not just going to be like
oh I made the choice not to engage
everyone's gonna be like that coward is
responsible for those people dying and
right now that pressure is not on any of
those teachers or even beyond that
teachers who choose not to carry a
weapon are going to be like those
teachers are cowards they should have
had guns and right now it's not even an
option so they don't have to deal with
that potential yeah I could
I can just see that being very bad for
the tea if a teacher was caring and they
didn't and they didn't you know save the
day because it's I don't know if you're
still on the line and you know with
handguns it takes a lot of persistent
training to stay proficient at shooting
a handgun to like an assault rifle
apparently I would argue that back ok do
you are like writing it's not that hard
honestly
well we're ok regardless of how hard it
is to shoot a handgun do you agree with
this concept of like kind of opening the
floodgates of holding teachers
responsible now for not engaging with
Apple computers again that comes down to
personal choice like when I guess people
shaming the security guard or a police
officer that he was that was his job yes
sir all right but people would say the
same but there could be more of a
safeguard against incident like that
where they have no one to protect well
as someone who grew up around guns I can
see that I mean I understand your your
perspective to me it just seems like
more and like how can you actually
assess like how great like I imagine
some desperado teachers like shooting
into the hallway and kids running
everywhere and then it's like god forbid
this poor son of a [ __ ] is trying to
help and he ends up you know killing a
kid it's just too chaotic yeah it's just
it's too chaotic that's that's my
concern as well yeah I got a I got a
friend that he's also a marine vet and
he concealed carries and and I'm fine
with that
sure I think that's I think that's fine
but when you put it into the teachers
hands and you're talking about a school
with shooting starts kids start running
there's all this confusion you don't
know how many shooters there are you
have a teacher run out there there's
saying a bunch of kids running away how
do you know who to shoot how do you if
you're going to hit them and if you're
not going to hit a kid and if you do hit
the wrong person then you're liable for
Diane life can you imagine that I mean
it's just it's it's overcomplicate
I feel like it's it's going in the wrong
direction where there's like I guess a
teen you said it really in a good way
where it's like people who support guns
don't see the option to remove guns it's
only more guns right but I don't know
I'm not saying any everybody that
supports guns sees it that way I mean I
own a gun
but I have my own oh [ __ ] bro oh yeah
Doug but I mean it's it's for it's for
personal defense reasons it's you know I
I think that you know everybody has a
different stance on on gun ownership not
everybody's one way or the other
sure well okay it's complicated but I
think the everybody's upset and wants to
do something about it I'm sure that's
true you know are you in favor of any
kind of gun control to prevent this Jake
are you still on the phone what do you
think about like raising the age or or
banning assault rifles and bump stocks
and stuff like that just out of
curiosity since I got here well I mean
in the 90s and through there we had a
ban on assault weapons and I mean that
didn't really help school shootings at
all I mean it's just I'm trying to
formulate my thoughts here I would
support like some regulations I guess I
common sense whatever way that could and
I mean yeah I mean just yeah sorry I'm
that's all right yeah your thanks for
calling it no sir none of us are
professional gun control night debaters
so that's totally fine going in and
sharing your experience god bless you
Jake appreciate you thanks for your
service yeah I think thank you all right
man peace god bless all right well we
ventured the murky waters of gun control
and I think we came out somewhat
unscathed anyway let's look let's tango
and learn do you Owen and gun yeah what
kind of gun do you own shotgun
yeah yeah we go well I mean you know we
never know yeah when you gotta kiss my
fat ashati we had some weird we had some
weird moments where people found out
where we lived
and it's not like I plan on you know
shooting somebody but it only takes it
takes one person to you know have the
wrong intentions obviously obviously
people coming to the house they you know
the interactions I had were not bad but
it only takes one person and well that
[ __ ] that happen to Gavin yeah then
that's and that's the that's the rare
obviously I don't think it's ever gonna
happen but yeah it's the rare occasion
where something like that did happen and
I just I messaged him like right right
after her but I was like dude like
that's insane he said you guys are okay
cuz that's ridiculous well for anyone
who doesn't know we're talking about
Gavin from the slo-mo mm-hmm just long
guys Ian says he has a student who was
there at the shooting Wow whoa Gavin
from the slow mo guys was at his house
with his girlfriend and somebody broken
in the middle of the night and they hid
in the closet and this guy was he drove
there from like Florida with the
intention to murder him
presumably them both both I don't know
Gavin and the stories he was jealous of
him yeah yeah like I had like thousands
of notes on his phone that really
infesting his love for maegor something
something to that extent
who knows but yeah he walked around the
house he I think he fired the gun once
when he entered the house which is kind
of weird like hey I'm here he kind of
announced here your presence I mean
thank God like that's that's nuts man
and then he couldn't find them cuz I hid
in the closet and then he walked out and
then he got shot and killed by the
police that is so I feel so bad for them
I'm gonna be honest after I heard that
I've got a shot II we don't but you I've
got it
well I have to tell you it's pretty easy
to get one
well shotguns I don't think shotguns are
compared to like a Saul rifle or a
handgun it's like pretty much made for
home defense
you can't miss you blast are asked to
space you can't shoot through your wall
and kill your neighbor's child could if
you had slugs okay but what is you're
loaded with [ __ ] armor-piercing
explosive yeah but yeah dragon's breath
no my wall will collapse when I shoot
once I think it's buck shots either
buckshot or birdshot but yeah because at
the time I was living with Anthony and
we had another roommate so I was like
okay hypothetically if somebody were to
come into the house I don't want to
shoot through the wall and kill Anthony
because that would be you know very bad
accidentally killed Anthony but in other
words no man I totally milk it I think
about it so apparently we've got Dillon
on the phone here who was at the school
in Florida during which is in zoom
Dillon hey how are you you're on the
line hi hi hey hey man so - so tell me
about your tell me about your background
you you were in Florida during the
shooting there um yeah I'm a Marjory
Stoneman Douglas student and I was on
the third floor and my creative writing
class
when everything was uh good I'm just
okay how are you I'm fine it's like it's
very like surreal like so everyone's
like kinda has like it don't doesn't
feel like it happened but more like
accepting that it did mm-hmm
so you were on the third floor I didn't
realize there was like floors how many
floors was on the school um well the
floor in the school has like a ton of
separate buildings where it goes from
one hundred twelve hundred it's pretty
much like the size of the college but
the random
or thousand-person oh wow he smokes yeah
so you were you when you were in the
building where it happened and you were
on the third floor and it happened on
the first floor
it happened specifically just in 1200
building okay and the shooter started on
the first floor and then the fire line
was pulled I mean his way up through the
staircase and then turn all the floors
and so like this whole conversation
around gun control following that like
what how do you feel about it um it's
it's both important but it feels very
sort of just unnecessary at the moment
because like it happened this is second
after the shooting people started
campaigning for it was just felt kind of
eyes and then of course like at funerals
there'd be like reporters they go what
do you think about plenty control ones
right one trying to mourn and so in that
way it does feel kind of like screwed
but it's a little too emotionally for
you guys yeah yeah like coming out of it
a police after I I can get behind like
people really campaigning for it by
going down to to Tallahassee and all
that sort of thing just try and like get
that modulated or however people are
campaigning it for it to be done but do
you do you agree with like I want to say
your your fellow students who are
campaigning like they're they're arguing
for a ban on a site rifles and raising
the purchasing a dry is that what it is
do you agree with yeah with Adam my
biggest agreement is probably with the
age limit outside of everything else
suggests I don't really have Faceman
American politics and really delivering
on anything other than age limit yeah so
that that's why I'm like I'm really just
like slowly putting support and raising
the age limit just that because it's
like a small step and you're saying like
we think if we can do the smaller things
we could eventually work towards the
larger things
yeah for sure it's it's all just a
ladder path that's what the way I like
the parties work we can't really do much
because like I'm pretty sure you have to
be 21 for like a handgun but things like
full angles didn't get a 88 so strange
out that yeah he meant the weird part
yeah yeah it's really weird I had it I
did take because I was thinking about
getting a handgun once and I had to take
a written test and have a permit to have
a handgun but for a shotgun and I yeah I
guess the rationale being the handguns
are concealable and so more dangerous
but why is assault rifle somehow like
all happy-go-lucky like hey salt rifles
for everyone that's strange I think it
just has something to do with the fact
that there's nothing that quality
there's nothing that truly qualifies
something as an assault rifle like a
semi-automatic right weapon with 20-plus
bullets right because it could be 20 it
could be 20 rounds it could be 30 rounds
and be 10 rounds it could be whatever
but it's still qualified as a rifle
right but then again I don't know
everything so I'm probably wrong there's
probably there's probably know how it
works yeah well yeah well do you think
the teachers should do you think if
teachers had weapons that it would have
made any difference for for you guys
there in that regard I feel like it
would only bring more risk just in the
way that the SWAT all right like legally
has to like conduct themselves like
let's say a streamer get SWAT and
they're like instructors like kill a dog
or anything that could be like a risk
leg so if there's a teacher with a
handgun they have no way of telling us
is going to happen under horde that's
sort of complex that's a group though
you know that that's always been my
biggest concern there's also concerns as
chickens not having to bring a weapon to
school but being able to take it from a
teacher right and there's a lot of
things like that and recently I think
about maybe a week ago there is a armed
teacher who shot himself in the leg
going to the bathroom but I think
actually I do your point about like
imagine the SWAT team going in and you
know
armed teachers around every corner
there's gonna be friendly fire yeah yeah
absolutely so I just think it's I too
much of a risk to run
I really wonder why what is the argument
in favor of selling the ia ar-15 that it
just seems like a military cool I guess
the well people I think people who argue
in favor it think that in the event that
their knees they need to revolt against
the government they need to have a ar-15
I think I think it's also the argument
the I think it's also the slippery slope
argument where they say if you take away
that then they're gonna take away this
and then this it's really just a matter
of how you interpret the the law it's
kind of so open that it's unfortunate
for everybody but anyway that's crazy
yeah we're glad you're okay thanks for
calling and sharing your experience with
us man and I'm yeah we're glad ya and
God bless she did all right my man
my my well that was unexpected whoa what
a trip how did you verify that was real
yeah because he said it's verified I'm
just curious
he sent his you sent pictures of his
grades with his name and social security
number we just went on a verification
Wow well thank you Dylan for calling in
that was that I hadn't consider that
that's so right you can't have a
freaking everybody walk around school of
guns and then the SWAT teams coming in
at the same time mm-hmm
yeah if there's a threat they don't have
time to hesitate be like oh is that a
teacher or is it a shooter yeah there
was a yeah there's videos from the
Parkland of kids recording the SWAT team
clearing the rooms and there's screaming
at kids that drop their phones because
they came I mean major how are they
supposed to know yeah are they supposed
to know there's
a gunman in there taking kids hostages
sure yeah definitely that kind of that
argument alone I think blocks the
discussion down it's yeah it's not gonna
convince anybody though I'm so when the
President himself is pushing for it what
can you say I don't know yeah but at the
same time Trump is also arguing in favor
of aid of raising the age limit to 21 so
yeah pretty interesting I think I think
he just wants to do what what the
popular sort of thing is so if
everyone's if everyone says yeah let's
let's do that then I think I think he's
gonna say yeah let's do that
alright well let's listen guys we've
talked about Papa John I've talked about
gun control we've talked about a lot of
really important issues and I think
we've made it a lot of we covered a lot
of ground and now not to downplay this
current one because I do think it's just
as important as all those I'd like to
introduce to you and television show
called my big fat pet makeover this is
just what I need
it's a it's a reality show about fat
pets and the owner and trainers efforts
to lose weight to further pets to lose
weight the best transition of content
are facing an epidemic is huge over half
our nation's pets are obese Wow oh my
god that board that I'm Travis Orson for
five Travis a fit guy and my pets are
even better yeah would that be funny if
he was a really obese okay so here's the
deal
like I understand the struggle people
have to maintain their own body weight
because your person and you make
decisions for yourself just don't feed
your pet you [ __ ] idiot just don't
give it food like it's hard to say that
about yourself because you know we
there's problems in the world and
everyone's got [ __ ] I'm kind of in the
support of fat cats also Garfield hello
so adorable
just don't give it any more beef jerky
little dog trainer in pet expert the
truth is fat pets just don't live as
long her ideal body weight should be
closer to 50 pounds goddamn they reeled
out like a cattle scale put that support
dog hanging from it it's not just about
helping pets it's about getting the
owners back on track as well pretty much
give her food every day off of my plate
that's gonna be a bad dog
shredder owns us he's got us wrapped
around his finger he's just chillin back
okay no it's gonna be a little fat boy
he's gonna be no tiny well usually my
own only a lot I'm on a mission to
helping decision pants make big changes
can you imagine so this continues the
discussion we were having but Hauser's
now shows for every flippin Mitch I
don't want to see that I don't want to
see the animals get skinny though
because you won't know because animals
are hilarious sorry so durable
I cannot believe you've said that I'm
sorry it's an epidemic and you know I
just can't I'm just not fat shaming okay
I like them the way they are you know we
I don't know if we talked about this
there's a show what's the name of that
channel with all the house makeovers I
keep forgetting Extreme Home Makeover
HGTV H H yeah so there's a show on there
now they've got a show for everything
they've got one with a black couple one
with a white couple one with two gay
dudes and it's all this channel blows my
mind it's all building up and fueling
this insane female fantasy because
they're all like couples usually and
their husband is like a dumb-dumb he's
like a dodo he's like a really fit guy
who's just like you know best honey I'm
gonna knock down this wall you know best
honey and it's like this insane female
fueled fantasy of like having this this
subservient husband that just builds
houses for you and you
lip even my mom from she's like her
dream job has been to flip houses mm-hmm
flip or flop flop every that is a show
yeah exactly the same
we made a cash offer and we got this
house for $400,000 tore down the walls
there was there's fungus in the walls
yeah I can't believe how much it's
costing us we signed it up making a
profit of $30,000 yeah I on to the next
flip I can shamelessly say I've watched
a lot of HGTV live at one point in my
life but it really is like they all
follow a very specific script where it's
like we only want to spend this much
when we found this house well it's
amazing oh no this wall you're gonna
have to redesign the whole kitchen you
notice that they say backsplash a lot
backsplash is very important when
they're done and they like put the house
on the market I I'm pretty sure they
just bring actors to be like people are
looking at the house there's no way a
normal person will be the backsplash
really the gray really pops on that
black spot yeah exactly
docks like that I think which one was it
love it or leave it
that was the one where they get like
three houses or house hunters these
house hunters a lot of those ones people
came out people that were on the show
came out they're like oh yeah we already
bought that house a lot of them like
they they had already bought the house
and the they just made the show like
they were considering the house and
considering two other houses but they
already reality show I know well my
favorite isn't flip or flop when they're
like we bought this house for 500,000
and after costs and upgrades that we're
at we need a seven hundred thousand
breakeven we're gonna list it for one
and a half million and then at the end
there like that well it's been three
months in the house is still in the
market we haven't gotten any offers why
I don't like [ __ ] you and your shitty
flip job yeah well anyway the point that
I had is that there's a show for every
single person this show and then there's
a new one on that channel called my
dream lottery home where they go with
people who have won the lottery
rags-to-riches it's like the female
fantasies off-the-chain well that's just
anything it's just wish fulfillment but
I mean it's incredible how they've like
are tapping so specifically and then are
also willing to come on the show yeah my
theory about that
is that the lottery sponsors that show
and they have in the agreement that if
you win you gotta buy a new house with
these guys that'd be funny because how I
mean how is it that they have this at
show every week we just want a hundred
million dollars and you know a couple
yokels I'm use that word whatever it's a
great word it's like a dumb okie another
great word I'm using well yeah it is
very derogatory but I don't think anyone
will take too much offense that was yeah
but it's just like a bunch of yeah no I
I watch I was watching that was like is
this HGTV cuz it's like shot the same
way with like the happy like couple like
we just want the best for a dog
well too bad we found those a
load-bearing wall and this dog we're
going to redesign this whole dog pretty
much um gosh man look at this gift we
often think of animals as you know
non-human watch this and tell me that
human the animals aren't human is this
gonna make me go vegan they're human my
dude they're clearly not human but this
isn't a great thing to watch okay
the story is that this monkey broke his
leg an event took it in for like three
weeks and fixed his leg here is the
moment when the monkey is reunited with
his family tell me this isn't the
sweetest damn thing you've ever seen in
your life look at these little monkey
[ __ ] give him their little guy a hug oh
my God look at this is this not heart so
the whole family comes out and hugs this
poor guy
it's amazing what if they're just
feeling him for warmth to see if they
could eat them this dude like I heard
there's something there's something
weird about dogs like when they lick
when they lick you it's not like a sign
of love it's actually something like
really messed up I don't I'm not a dog
like that yeah it's it's not it's not
like oh I love you yeah it's like a
dominance thing or it's some sort of oh
you guys are betas total betas barbra
streisand cloned her dogs speaking of
which have you heard about that
yeah she spent a hundred thousand
dollars to Cologne she made two dogs
from her dog that died a couple years
ago from its DNA and made exact Leopard
history says who cloned her dog not once
but twice yeah so the Entertainer told
variety that two of her dogs Miss
Scarlet and Miss violet were cloned from
her 14 year old pet Samantha who died
last year
she says the cells were harvested from
Sam's mouth and stomach but she says the
clones have different personalities
Streisand has a third dog of the same
breed which she says anything about that
I'm more focusing on the way this
woman's reading the teleprompter she
seems like she wants to kill herself
she's like Barbra Streisand you know hey
if you got the money and we all we all
know that stray sea does oh my god I was
just curious cuz they're like $100,000
that's nothing to her I was like I don't
know how rich is Barbra Streisand it's
worth like 400 million yeah man
what I guess I missed the Streisand he
was a little bit before night Connie I
didn't know that she was so big she was
yeah she's super star is that what they
call it the Streisand of thing is that
when you make 400 million dollars yeah I
could definitely understand people doing
that I wouldn't do that because there's
so many dogs and pounds if you want a
dog just go to the freakin pound and get
a dog but yeah I have a friend
her parents lost their little tiny dog
and they
but an identical dog in a totally
different state because they needed it
to be just like the last one so I know
those people would do the same exactly
is it a desecration of life to like
clone a dog I almost like to revive it
and it's a strange thing I didn't know
it was already an option like yeah
apparently for rich people you can just
I didn't know that was an option wait so
like a rich person does that for their
kid yeah
yeah I think that is illegal but that
would be a creepy day when that does
happen I don't think that humans have
been cloned yet that we know of that way
yeah um would you clone little Fredrik
it's hard I love him so much
let's clone him now let's have our army
shredders in there [ __ ] it I'll pay I'll
pay I'll pay 10 million for that take
out a loan all right speaking of animals
that watch this one for a while Boston
Dynamics who make the life like creepy
robots then haunt our dreams
this is their new robot why do they have
to make them look like they're straight
out of half-life yeah like they
intentionally harvesting my nightmares
what like make it in place tell colors
just make it seem more friendly yeah the
death machine to see more friendly put a
smiley face on it this this hundred
million dollar robot opens doors what a
guy and quietly
don't wait yeah that was very very very
nice you wouldn't do that for a human
though cuz they remember everything well
they definitely took the door opener job
oh my gosh all those poor guys found
open doors
watch out i'm jobs are going out the
window
every day now we've spoken about deep
fakes on the show before hmm and how
people are using famous actresses face
to put on famous porn stars faces but
did you know that deep fakes are not
just for pornography anymore
in fact now they are kinds of
applications really useful elegant
applications for example Nic Cage on the
face of every movie star ever oh yes dr.
Pavel I'm CIA
everybody's winking you don't get to
bring friends I'm not my friend
oh no not everybody just him on the line
I was fibbing and why would I want them
they were trying to prize like bloated
Nic Cage that's weird
[Music]
you know like this is very confusing
yeah why why only pornography why this
is way more valuable to us who actually
is that Tom
it's our support Harris this is all this
is radar okay
yeah this is this is what history should
have and I love the pectin inspirational
music - to go along with it
all right the world is changing my
friends it's weird it's a brave new
world out here they saw that they
replaced Henry Cavill mustache like he's
like a 500 dollar computer and did it
better than Warren about yeah yeah yeah
that's that is true don't we talk about
that shitty yeah yeah he was he liked it
you did anything to say bet about it
gotta have to be so bad but we don't
have anymore brakes oh I'm gonna power
through this drinking that's when you
have to pee you don't drink yeah but
I've not really found that to be once I
have to pee I don't think that adding
more liquid is necessarily gonna I don't
know maybe psychological but I feel like
it's gotta make it worse I mean you have
to be right to an extent yeah then some
for some people like the hot food on a
hot day so maybe who does that
crazy people you know I read in Israel
the Bedouins drink hot tea on hot dates
because it makes them sweat and it cools
them down that did not make sense to me
because you don't need help sweating hmm
I called him a liar they kicked me out
out of Israel yeah it was a bad day I
have a bunch of gifts here which is kind
of stupid to watch but I think cracking
up so much this drunk guy at a party I
couldn't even believe this was real he's
got he's trying to get to the bathroom
and he's mistaken himself in the mirror
for somebody else that this guy is
blocking his path and it's just no I've
never seen anything like it in my life
what so he's trying to let himself by
he's like go ahead and now he's getting
like I just when does he get this is
like a mr. bean episode of your laughs
oh you I'm watching mr. bean oh is he
starting to realize it he's like oh wait
I don't think so no thank you
no I'm still going
go ahead man problem buddy
starting to fight Wow
oh is it setting in yeah maybe he's like
oh maybe I've had enough to drink wow I
didn't know that was possible he's got
like he's on like the monkey level of or
even lower maybe like shredder you know
like be that [ __ ] up but you can still
stand somebody said it must may have
been a touch of dementia which kind of
makes it less funny oh why do they have
to make it sound like I'd make it that
thing I'm sure it was just how gall
let's just so we can enjoy it this blew
my mind a little bit this is podcasts
just turned into fun facts I'm sorry you
guys you ever heard of why do you say it
plan in Hebrew ela that's you oh that
doesn't help me mm-hmm
the most European languages they call it
like uber man or something aubergine
aubergine aubergine aubergine and
everyone's like oh eggplant Americans
are [ __ ] idiots oh well look what
eggplants look like when they're growing
eggs this club so much this was so great
kit boga so this dude I guess makes it a
habit of messing with scammers on
history and they set up a virtual drive
on his computer because what they do is
like oh man you've got you've got a
virus or you owe the IRS and I need to
get on your commission any computer and
they feeling their you know files or
whatever and so he sets up this virtual
drive and gives him access and he has
all these folders set up information
because you're not having a protection
on a computer okay so he's got folders
Bank of Qatar cords memes nudes and
taxes guess which one he goes for
first a lot of people from naked
mole-rats
I love the first thing he does is great
to the news if it's on Twitter made him
get me banned on YouTube I've noticed
this thing on my phone where if I'm
getting a call from a scammer now it
shows up bright red and it says probably
scammer it's so cool yeah I had I had a
woman call me and she started the phone
call with hello this is not a scam
my name is tell me everything yeah she's
like my name is Annie and by the and
again this is not a scam call and it's
like no well the the funny thing about
that probably not it probably a scam
warning is it makes me more likely to
answer in a way cuz I'm and Matthew I
get intrigued yeah tell me more about
this likely scam guys this that's about
it what right then almost 5 yeah why but
are you free miniature how that's
blowing my mind well there's a couple
more videos I want to go over ok I got
some more stories I put together a
collection of the awful Olympians I
don't know how people so awful at their
chosen sport end up in the Olympics I
guess because like apparently every
country s best athletes go sure so if
their best athlete happens to not be
able to swim then so be it
as it
was the case with this young fine man
here who was from some African country
was this the one and also this great
stuff after two false starts and
everyone one of the hundred made is
[Applause]
probably a better swimmer than the clock
is birdie now Hg he's getting so slow do
you think he's starting to wonder like
how long is this pool I don't remember I
don't think he's got coaches
[Music]
[Applause]
the world record was like 48 seconds to
get two minutes tough enough so a parent
so whatever African country is from they
didn't send Olympians so he's like hey
I'm gonna qualify and they're like
you're the best I think we got to go to
a pool and try to beat his record we're
actually pretty good swimmers oh really
mm-hmm
I mean that guy is really much healthier
than me though yeah but I mean hey I'd
give it a shot well so that's one that's
classic as it gets this was from the
most recent Olympics and I don't know
the backstory out of the gate my doggy
many men
get it my dude get it but I think this
one actually isn't the Olympics but
maybe a qualifier mix or something okay
I just I don't get the mentality these
people like I'm gonna learn how to ski
during an Olympic qualifier
[Music]
you've got it buddy
I put a little dissolve in there he's
got like all the professional
I think that's the fastest way to ski is
to walk sideways that hurts
Oh is he gonna bomb down this hill oh no
he's gonna eat it yeah I'd love to see a
competition between I love to see a
bizarre-o Olympics with him and peers on
his skill level yeah it's almost like
the WB superstar version of the Olympics
I can relate to this too much because I
I grew up cross-country skiing with my
parents it's the worst sport ever
invented
I once game once and I'll never go again
Oh downhill skiing is fun I went with my
friend and his dad who are like skiing
superstars and I am NOT an athletic guy
by default and they're like oh let's go
skiing it's gonna be fun I'm like cool
yeah never tried it they're like yeah
don't worry about it we'll take care of
you so first thing they give me first of
all they don't give me skis they gave me
ski blades which is some hot new thing
that's in fashion oh it's a tiny yeah
I'm sure that's like you have to be kind
of experienced to stop around on those
right less stable like go right down the
bunny slope a couple times so I fall in
my ass a couple times when I make it
down and I'm feeling pretty good and
they're like okay let's go to the top of
the hill and do and and go down together
I'm like cool that sounds fun I'm ready
so they take me down a black diamond hmm
thinking back on this how could they do
that to me these were your friends it
was my best friend and his dad I think
they must have secretly despised me
they're trying to kill you for sure so
so there's different levels of ski
slopes black I'm in his expert level and
so I'm bombing down this hill is so
[ __ ] steep and I'm just like I'm not
going down this because you know you
bomb down the hill and there's like
netting followed by a death drop and so
I'm like no I'm not like I'm scared out
of my mind so I'm zigzagging one foot at
a time it takes me like an hour to get
down this hill people are zipping past
me being like a [ __ ] idiot are like
it's dangerous frankly yeah
it's like driving down the freeway at 10
miles per hour why are you doing it and
they're standing at the bottom of the
hill waiting I mean I was awful
they're like damn it he made it thinking
back on that man I think he's tried
again
do you like skiing I I am a snowboarder
but I was like bro yeah yeah but I think
I'm gonna give that up and start skiing
whenever I get back to the slopes I love
you let's go I want to get actually it's
done but we should do jumping up in
Tahoe
right now brah I love the gear up
Northstar or Sugar Bowl or Kirkwood damn
man you know maybe we'll head up
heavenly if you're feeling real bougie
I'm gonna go me and he's gonna take me
down like a double black diamond man all
you gotta know is pizza pie french fry
all you don't know pizza what does that
mean oh is that like because you have
these skis and you want to slow down or
stop you put your skis like this it's a
pipe pizza pie you're ready to roll
french fries Raymond oh yeah I'll take
you guys I got you all the sudden skiing
sounds fun again feel like I even
through therapy and I'm ready for snow
sports yeah you definitely skied with
[ __ ] and that's that's the number
one I've always cherished their
friendship it was Kyle my dear good
friend from my childhood and his dad who
I've always loved and respected and in
retrospect I think they wanted me to die
yeah I took Anthony skiing one time and
but they him and his girlfriend at the
time they they were on the bunny hill
and they were getting used to it and I
was kind of I was going off with my
friend I guess I wasn't being a good
friend because I didn't I didn't help
them and we're going up a ski lift and I
see I think it was both of them and they
were just bombing straight down well we
don't know how to stop so we're just
gonna go straight down they made it they
did one run and then wiped out they were
going we're good it's terrifying because
you can just run away there's like a
real adventure there is and it seems
when you're doing it real danger I don't
know how much but it seems very real
danger because you can always just eat
[ __ ] and it's
so you'd be but I don't know how those
drops because it looks like you would
die but I don't know if you live yeah
sure you could die you can find it right
into a tree yeah there's not generally
trees in the bunny no in the bunny hill
nor anywhere else really yeah but widely
groomed yes trail exactly unless you're
going balls to the wall usually have to
work I want to go I want to do it yeah
I'm gonna put some snow blades on you
and take you to the top and give you a
shove down the trail I'm all I'm just
plotting to get your MacBook Air wait
what I wanted to toss your ass down the
Black Diamond and with her MacBook Air I
just be like got your back it's an
elaborate ploy to murder you for a
laptop well try zips on down so there's
one other Olympic knucklehead
this guy's not really not clad but it
was kind of funny in the Olympics
oh the the lady that scammed her way
into the Olympics so what's the story
you she scammed her away what do you
mean or is that just a general statement
well she there was some sort of thing
where she found out that as long as she
didn't crash or something during the
competition's leading up to the Olympics
that she would qualify for the oh
interesting strategy yeah she nobody
told her she would win or no one told
her she couldn't win so she goes this is
like the massive trick she's supposed to
be doing like ten eighties and I can
really do this and she's just cruising
down that this is a routine which is
impressive for like the layman but yes
the Olympics I mean I guess you'd still
be a pretty profession skier to do how
to do the halfpipe sure and she does a
little she does a little 360 too
but there she goes like oh yeah my mom
loop when you snowboard and do you do
[ __ ] some tricks do you Brian
when I was 15 I was like I'm gonna
travel terrain park I want to see if I
could start doing some jumps and hit
some boxes and stuff and and then I
found out that that that hurts when you
fail it and I'm not I'm not really big
on injury so either yeah yeah so I I
tried out the terrain park a few times
found it wasn't my thing fractured my
wrist and that was done oh yeah I had a
similar experience my dad owned a bike
shop and so a lot of my friends were
into BMX extreme building ramps and
hitting fat air they got the sweet knobs
on the backs of their wheels sprout
knobs in case your buddy wanted to ride
for some reason Oh another knobs were
for grinding bag yeah well I hit a fat
ramp mmm and I hate [ __ ] spectacularly
and I never tried it again which is sad
cuz I always thought they were so cool
they were you just are I think yeah I
want that's that was what was said I
wanted to be cool yeah I did the same
thing with skateboarding I bought like a
20 dollar skateboard from big five and I
was like I'm gonna try to skateboarding
thing cuz my friend had started doing
and I think it was I think I was maybe
10 or something and and our neighborhood
the sidewalks sucked
I hit a crack eight [ __ ] it was like
yeah it's not my favorite game I'm gonna
be I'm not gonna be a skateboard guy
there's really I feel like we are the
same in that like the minute that I have
any sense of danger and I'm all yeah I'm
just like I'm never doing this again I'm
just a giant [ __ ] Riot's no worth it
not worth it for me my dad was the big
risk taker and aren't you so glad that
we never had to serve in a war I would
be completely worthless well I mean it
could still happen
nah we're too old if they turn through
enough people I've got what is supported
was it the Trump said I got nice prints
man I got a I got a oh I bone the bone
spurs I got boomers man yeah I got uh
I'm fat
does that an excuse if you could maybe
like link some sort of like athletic
deficiency to that I don't know I have
asthma I don't know if that would get me
out
sounds good nice a promising lead I
don't think they draft people over 30
I mean I don't think there's anything
preventing them from I mean we're all
registered maybe 35 is where they cut it
off I need it you know what I think
we're good anyway
I'm a giant coward hmm and I would be
worthless on the frontline yeah and I'm
very happy and actually I think about
this often how fortunate are we to have
never been sent to that meat grinder
during our lifetime Vietnam just [ __ ]
like vomit eyes the whole generation did
daddy thank well I mean we're still
technically in a war the longest one
ever so which ones there's always time
which one is that
Afghanistan oh yeah they never draft
anyone though
no but it's still going on well so
there's always there's always hope even
it's very big brother
it's very 1984 isn't it that
never-ending war mmm I've never I don't
I don't read I've never read a book
there's a never-ending war oh is that
what it is it's weird it's I just read
it recently so I'm I sound like a
[ __ ] like let me reference this book
which I've already referenced three
times and oh you sound really smart in
that book the theory was that there
would be never-ending Wars to waste
resources to keep people poor because
technology gets better and we get more
efficient we had to find a way to keep
the classes separated and to keep people
poor so they had ongoing war so they
could literally just destroy resources
yeah let's buy some truth that it's a
book he's having a chicken crisis oh
that this is much better news this is a
after switching delivery services KFC in
the UK were left without any chicken at
all almost 700 of all the kick of KFC's
in the UK were closed down with no
flippin chicken to speak of drama and
pandemonium ensued for example here I've
got a hold a bunch of media about this
chicken crisis
how careful he was at the tape sorry we
are closed
the police have warned people stop
calling KFC about where added chicken
imagine calling the police about that
this is real this is real bad this this
tweet really kind of solidified it for
me
disaster took the grandkids out to
dinner at KFC a wonder fine to see that
it shut down some chicken shortage took
them to McDonald's but it's not the same
crying I can't show weakness in front of
them I wish you would have kept it a
little more straight because I but
there's but there's people that that get
legitimately upset about that kind of so
yeah I'm sure you plan your whole day
you go to kid justice in this world is
frankly immeasurable I'm just happy to
know that it's not just America with
people like that it's yeah it gives me a
little bit more more comfort you know
well you know they framed it all [ __ ]
up they're like oh man aren't you what'd
you do what'd you do I went to Burger
King and they're like frame at all like
this nutty lady complaining please have
to tell people to stop calling here this
is a tweet from the UK Police Department
please do not contact us about the KFC
crisis it is not a police matter if your
favorite eatery is not serving the menu
that you desire are you sure it's not a
police matter
the KFC crisis excuse me I pay your
salary with my taxes I say what's a
crisis word I call number one you guys
need to head over to rouse and get that
chicken the KFC I'll be waiting at least
the chicken is back you'll all be
relieved to find out
but if injustice couldn't get any any
worse
gravy shortages are now over
the chicken returned I mean that's
arguably the best part of KSC is the
great school shootings gun control yeah
and now now this I'm expected stomach
this on top of everything no enough is
enough
you know I was told when I was in
Australia that there KFC is better can
confirm why I think it's a chicken do
you think it's though Wow yeah I think
it's the chicken that they get the that
they get that there's they're supplied
with I think I want to ever been
fighters is it more expensive there um
compared to LA probably not I mean the
chicken specific oh oh I don't know I
mean the alcohol is a lot more expensive
in Australia that's the one that's the
one place where we got him
you know they got cheap alcohol so much
better than that everyone who goes to
Australia's like loves it and you know
as things are heating up with Russia
Putin's bragging about he's got some
nuclear bombs that can't be shot down
I'm looking in to New Zealand's visa
program because post Malone is looking
for a nuclear bunker I'm looking for a
nuclear safe country yeah nobody really
hates New Zealand yet who's gonna drop a
bomb on his Iran does Oh
Sauron got me got me like but seriously
if there's one country if bombs started
falling they would be fine New Zealand
too big they're just like they're
chickens to deck
they can't you mean Australia ice too
big well New Zealand's close and they
kind of smell like Santa that would be
easier you know there's gonna be too
much fallout because there's New York
there there's Seattle there's all these
cut there's too much border drama I
don't know I
something with Australia you think there
will be the future they just sound cool
like there it's like cool let's go let's
go it's real cool do you think that we
could just move there just pay off some
official no
there's probably some I mean a lot of
countries I know I knew at least to get
into the u.s. they have like a special
visa program where if you can prove that
you're a celebrity like an important
tell me more well you got you guys are
already you know citizens so you don't
even need to worry about that but of
Australia no I mean in order to get into
the u.s. if you can prove that yes
like if you're exceptional talent or
yeah yeah I don't know about Australia
you're not a lost ralien immigration
lawyer I'm still brushing why I need you
yeah all right well anyway give me about
a year we'll move to New Zealand that'd
be fun let me stay any guess house are
you worried about the stability of the
world in yeah it's gonna work itself out
you're an optimist yeah I mean it's that
or nuclear war and which case it's all
[ __ ] at yeah point of surviving yeah
although like after after like the the
Kim jong-un stuff started heating up I
started like reading those articles that
was like the best places to hide for the
fallout that tone is perfect yeah yeah I
mean those articles were getting some
serious hits daytime oh yeah but then I
was like thinking I was like okay so I
need to like get to a place that has you
know that's underground that you started
scheming on how to save your ass yeah
and I was thinking okay if I'm at the
office they have an underground parking
garage that's better than then in my
house which would structure okay it's
like the 1950s again though yeah yeah
and also kim jeong-hoon
AKA law rocket boy in the words of our
great leader he's can hit la yeah mm-hmm
we're the only ones
he's not gonna bump guam yeah do you
think he would hit the valley or
downtown though good question i thought
about that what would the boy downtown
yeah doesn't I think I'd be fine first
symbolism sake and also it's a financial
sector I mean well actually I'll
probably just hit both I mean they
probably got enough you think they got
enough what Austin post Malone has an
out he bought a house yeah I'm not gonna
say we're obviously but he's mapped out
the place not only that
don't get hit by a nuke but it's also
safe from nuclear winds whoa
so what I series about this yes so what
I need now is like I need to train as a
helicopter pilot mm-hmm so that when
it's like oh when I get that text like
they got in Hawaii izip up and I zip out
mmm there's no freeway [ __ ] there's
no tunneling it's up and out like
Superman yeah and I'm like peace out
everybody that's a good plan I would
just be cowering in my house and just
crying and wishing why I didn't prepare
better damn it Ethan with this
helicopter yeah okay can you pick me up
bro not that far away my man what about
you yell are you worried about the
stability of the world mm-hmm I come
from Israel I got I got I got like a
Korean uber driver one time during like
some of the hullabaloo a little bit
before the nukes the the new nuke stuff
and and he's just like yeah North Korea
always just has a bomb and they're
always just threatening and it and he
was like I think he was 40-something he
lived he grew up in South Korea with
that threat always looming and nothing
ever happening so his his whole stance
on it was yeah what can you do yeah dan
what about you is the world good - we're
all gonna end dan I think I think it's
begun the nukes kinda begun all right I
have to pee so bad I can't believe it's
been over two hours already you did it
happy weekend everyone
I asked you first of all I've saved this
little nugget for all you guys who've
stuck through to the end guess who's
coming on not next week but the week
after you'll never guess Bill Nye the
Science Guy
no but it's weirdly it's Bob Saget oh
don't bring any children yeah it's got a
dirty mouth Batman yeah
yeah that's just I'm excited it's so
it's such a twist right
yeah I'm Saget and it's just like
everywhere you look so hard it's a SAG I
don't remember the rest of the theme
song for a full house hmm I never
watched lost I was a America's Funniest
Home Videos so that that week we have
the live show and Bob Saget is gonna be
who shows yeah gonna be Reid's gonna be
a big week guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you have a great
terrific blessed wonderful weekend
just remember Papa John is on hold right
now if you were thinking about getting
to eat some pie consider picking out
pizza the official sponsor of the NFL
and hopefully whoever pays me more I
have how can you look that no pizza
company has ever paid me still to this
day like whoever's it's some some
marketing pizza person a little seizures
seizures yeah they're not gonna give you
money now you know DiGiorno you're
thinking too big man you guys think
smarter too stoned does that still exist
tombstone pizza tombstone sounds bad
it's like what it's like yeah you're
gonna die if you eat fat ass Red Baron I
eat that for many years does your nose
not bad I had a slice of that recently
and it's real saucy and I was like yeah
boy did you know I like that was Joe's
Trader Joe's pizzas man those are the
real deal Trader Joe's frozen game is
off the chain all right see you next
time guys thanks for watching